hello everyone
welcome to simply learn's youtube
channel in this session
we will be discussing about
multi-threading in java but before we
begin
let me tell you guys that we have daily
updates on multiple technologies
if you are a tech geek in a continuous
hunt for latest technological trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon
to never miss an update from simply
learn now without further ado
let's get started with our agenda for
today's discussion
at first we'll discuss about what
exactly is multi-processing
then we will discuss the types of
multi-processing
after that we will understand what
exactly is a thread
then we will learn multi-threading in
java
followed by that we will understand what
is the life cycle of a thread in java
then we will execute a simple program
based on multi-threading in java
and finally we will wind up the session
by discussing the advantages of
multi-threading
in java i hope i made myself clear with
the agenda
now let's get started with our first
point that is what exactly
is multi-processing
so what is multi-processing so
multi-processing
is a procedure where you utilize your
processor to the maximum
it's basically dividing the instruction
you give to your cpu into multiple parts
and
each segment is assigned a separate
thread to execute that particular task
now moving forward we will discuss about
the types of multiprocessing
so basically there are two different
types of multi-processing
the first one is processed-based
multi-processing
and the second one is the thread-based
multi-processing
so our point of discussion is the
thread-based multi-processing
now we will understand what exactly is a
thread
so a thread is an individual lightweight
and the smallest unit of a given process
there are multiple threads in a single
process and each thread is independent
of each other
so basically whenever you assign an
instruction to your processor
it divides the instructions into
segments and
all these segments are assigned with a
single thread
and the best part of using threads is
in case if one of your threads is not
operational or it is dead
then the rest of the threads will not be
affected your process will not be
hearted
so that's the major advantage of
multi-threading we'll discuss all the
advantages in the upcoming parts
now after the definition we will
understand a little more about the
thread
so basically threads are interdependent
sometimes you may have to switch between
one process to another process
or you might have to switch between one
thread and another thread
so as shown in the above figure the
thread is executed inside the process
and there is
context switching between the threads
there can be multiple processes inside
the operating system
and one process can have multiple
threads as well
now moving forward we will understand
more about the thread lifecycle
so basically a thread life cycle is
decided in
five different stages so the first stage
is the new next is runnable after that
running and followed by running you
either have to wait
or you can also send your thread into
the death state
based on the requirements of your
process now we will discuss each one of
them in a bit more detail
first we will discuss about the new
stage
the first stage in a thread is always
called the new stage
in this stage the brand new thread is
created and is kept
on hold no process is allocated to it or
it will not start executing until a
process has been
assigned to it after the creation of the
new thread
the next stage is the runnable stage it
is where a thread gets assigned
to the process and the thread is engaged
it is ready to get executed
the next stage is where the os or the
process scheduler
begins the execution of the process
using the thread and that stage is
called as
the running stage once the process is
running it can continue in that
stage until the process gets finished or
sometimes it has to wait because of the
response that it needs from another
process that stage is called as waiting
and in case
if the threat has finished executing the
process it can directly enter into the
death state
now we will discuss what is waiting
stage so as discussed the waiting stage
is where
the current thread is in the weight
situation as it needs a response
from another thread there are two ways
one it might have to wait for the
response from the other thread and going
to wait or it might finish the execution
stage and directly enter into the death
state
so the dead state is the last stage
where the thread gets killed after the
process execution
after the termination stage the thread
enters into the dead condition
now that we have understood a thread and
what is its life cycle
let us execute a simple program based on
multi-threading
as you can see on my screen we have a
simple program for multi-threading
here my class is multi-thread and we are
extending the thread class to create
threads into our program
now we are going to create three simple
threads that are thread a thread b
and thread c and all those threads will
be
executing one single message that is
printing the
thread is operational message onto the
print console
now let's directly execute this program
and see the output
so as you can see the program got
successfully executed and all these
three
threads are activated and they are
executing the job of printing a simple
message
now let us move ahead and discuss the
advantages of using multi-threading in
java so following are the advantages of
using multi-threading in java
they are threads can perform multiple
operations at the same instance and this
will save a lot of time
multi-threading offers improved
throughput and multi-threading
minimizes the system resources and
program structure
is really simplified and it offers
superior application responsiveness and
finally
it improvises the communications between
the different processes in the project
now with that we have come to an end of
this tutorial on multi-threading
in java if you have any queries
regarding the topics discussed in this
particular tutorial
then please feel free to let us know in
the comment section below and our team
of experts
will be happy to resolve all your
queries until next time thank you
stay safe and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here